abolitionist author David Reynolds
details one of the most controversial
figures of the Civil War this talk is an
hour thank you very much it's wonderful
to be here and I'm very happy with the
reception of my book it's been one of
the most widely review books in America
over the last few weeks and I think the
interest has been sparked because for
many years John Brown was virtually
hidden from you and perhaps getting
again that a little later the reasons
for that and it's only been kind of
recently that he has come back to the
fore and been treated in a very sort of
responsible way by certain historians
and I hope to be part of this
recuperation of John Brown and to put
him back where he should really be in
the very center of American history he
was the only abolitionist who repeatedly
took up arms against slavery both before
the Civil War during this period during
the period of so-called bleeding Kansas
in the 1850s he took the step of leading
a party of eight followers who raided
some cabins on Pottawatomie Creek and
slaughtered five pro-slavery settlers
with swords two years later Brown led 20
men into the slave state of Missouri and
forcibly liberated 11 slaves killing one
white man in the process and then
striking with the blocks 1,200 miles
halfway across the nation to Detroit
where they took a boat to Canada and to
freedom his boldest move was his raid on
Harpers Ferry Virginia now it's West
Virginia with 21 men in an effort to
liberate the slaves in that area and
then flee with them to the nearby
mountains with the idea of making
periodic raids on plantations and freed
slaves who would then become part of his
ever growing army of liberation what
actually happened is that he did take
over Harpers Ferry pretty easily he
liberated many slaves in the area he
took white hostages but he stalled too
long at the ferry and he was captured by
federal troops under robert e lee he was
imprisoned he was brought to trial found
guilty on three counts including treason
and he was hanged on December 2nd 1859
now Brown dated his hatred against
slavery from the time when he was aged
12 and he saw a slave boy that he
befriended being beaten with a shovel an
incident that made him quote swear
eternal war against slavery as he put it
from a very young age then hatred of
slavery flamed in the very core of his
being yes but why I mean after all slave
boys and girls and their parents were
being beaten and driven outside everyday
and nobody had John Brown's extreme
reaction what was it about round the
provoked this revulsion I show in my
book that it was the unusual brand of
religion that his family espoused he was
born in 1803 flush period the Republican
period not too long after the
eradication of the Constitution which
separated the church and state in
America and when this occurred America
American Protestantism was sent spinning
in all kinds of directions today there
are more than 250 Protestant
denomination denominations and sects in
America and this proliferation really
began during this period and some very
original sometimes shocking practices
emerged under the name of Protestant
Christianity you know 9 in New York the
Protestant perfections under John
Humphrey Noyes practice complex marriage
whereby each woman had many husbands
complex indeed all right elsewhere the
Mormon Church instituted polygamy in the
name of the Bible the Mormon leader
Brigham Young reportedly had 52 wives
then there were the shakers who practice
celibacy the millwrights who gather on
hillsides and white robes waiting for
the end of the world October 1844 and
then it didn't come then so they put it
off for a year and eventually it fed
into seventh-day Adventism or one
version of it fed into that now as
creative as some of these offshoots
of American Protestantism were none was
as as perhaps creative and and and and
his bizarre really as the form that took
hold in the family of Owen and Ruth
John Brown's parents this family
religion which has never - never exactly
spelled out in the early going but all
is acted upon by the family went
something like this I happen to be a
Caucasian and a Calvinist Protestant
you're black
you're Indian Asian another in that
ethnicity you're Catholic Jewish atheist
another religion this doesn't matter in
the relationship that I have with you
all that matters is mutual respect of
each other's rights nothing else counts
and for the brown this unspoken Creed
has special meanings for their feelings
about the millions of enslaved blacks in
America at that time John Brown would
always say that his abolitionism was
rooted in two things the golden rule and
the Declaration of Independence but
there was nothing intrinsically
anti-slavery about either of these many
southerners of that day who were very
ardent Christians used the Golden Rule
to defend slavery they said they were
doing blacks a huge favor by bringing
them to America exposing them to the
so-called blessings of Christian
civilization and as for the Declaration
of Independence its author of course
Thomas Jefferson inherited over 300
slaves it was a slaveholder as were many
others who venerated the Declaration
so the Brown's family interpretation of
the golden rule and the Declaration of
Independence were very quirky and odd
odd ones for that particular day as
progressive as they might seem to us
today they're they're very kind of
bizarre all the family members were
strict Calvinists John Brown's favorite
theologian with Jonathan Edwards sinners
in the hands of an angry god many of you
perhaps have heard that sermon although
John Brown believed that he'd been
predestined he was a Calvinist
predestination to do so actually may be
best regarded as what I see is a chance
mutation of American religion at a time
when it was splintering and fragmenting
in the Brown family the righteous angry
God of the Old Testament was fused with
anti-slavery passion to produce
new militancy a new kind of abolitionism
not that John Brown was instinctively a
warrior to the contrary as young men he
refused to the enlist in the Army on
moral grounds it was only the later
violence of pro-slavery mobs that
converted him to being what he'd regard
as being a soldier of the Lord Brown was
also distinguished by his avoidance of
the racism of his day ironically many of
the other anti-slavery figures of his
age were tinged with their prevalent
racism of that era Lincoln thought that
blacks and whites couldn't live on equal
terms in America because of what was
regarded as essential differences
between the races and for a long time he
advocated colonization or shipping
emancipated blacks abroad to places like
Liberia or Central America once that
once they were free
another anti-slavery figure the
scientist Louis Agassiz claimed that a
typical black person had the brain of an
undeveloped white fetus while the very
ardent anti-slavery politician Cassius
Clay stated that the natural place for
blacks was in the tropical Sun eating
bananas Monte these were all
anti-slavery people for John Brown in
contrast openness to people of different
ethnicities was in his blood as a boy
growing up in the Ohio wilderness he
befriended Native American children in
the Woods was initiated into a tribe and
kind of a place ceremony learned the
Native American language later when he
was a farmer in Pennsylvania white
neighbor came to him and complained
about the Indians in the region asking
John Brown if he'd join him and taking
guns to drive off the natives and Brown
replied I will have nothing to do was so
mean and act I was sooner take my gun
and help drive you out of the country
and Brown was really the first white
American to apply fully the notions of
equality and brotherhood to the issue of
race there were some others who escaped
racism racism particularly the Quakers
certain Quakers but he was distinguished
by his complete immersion in black
culture black American culture not only
was he close to prominent blacks
Frederick Douglass Harriet Tubman I
think he probably respected Harriet
Tubman
more than any single individual that he
ever met I firmly believe that but he
chose to live among the more obscure
blacks in the colony at North Elba in
upstate New York near Lake Placid it was
place where fugitive the fugitive slaves
have gone and he went up there to help
them develop economically and one fit a
white visitor to North elbow the popular
novelist Richard Henry Dana was shocked
when he stumbled upon Brown's cabin up
there and there were several blacks
sitting at the table and Brown made a
point of treating them with the Saint in
exactly the same way that he treated the
famous Sir Richard Henry Dana and and
the other whites present and interests
every one president is mr. and mrs. and
again the this kind of treatment for
someone like Dana was was sort of
totally off-the-wall and very shocking
also Brown's military plans stemmed
largely from from blacks particularly
slave revolts in the American South and
the rebellions by the mountain based
Maroons of the West Indies among his
great heroes were Nat Turner the leader
of the bloody slave rebellion in 1831
another hero was sink way of Amistad
Fame and Toussaint L'Ouverture who led
the revolt against white European
domination in Haiti Brown's sympathy for
the downtrodden emerged partly from his
lifelong status as a struggling
businessman who over who almost hovered
near the poverty line few influential
people in history have failed some
miserable in so many different pursuits
as John Brown he failed as a Tanner as
Shepherd a cattle trader a horse breeder
a lumber dealer or real estate
speculator and a wool distributor why
these failures well Brown did have to
provide for his growing family he had 20
children with two wives
you've heard of Pablo Cheaper by the two
dozen and cheaper uh he almost achieved
two dozen but you know we think that's a
lot a lot of kids but actually the
average family back then had about seven
to nine children in here to two
different wives and only eight of his
children outlived him it was under back
then a lot of people had large families
that diseases the white
he lost four kids within two weeks
because of a disease that doesn't even
exist today so there was a lot of kind
of overpopulation and then with the
expectation that's sadly enough the some
of these kids just just wouldn't survive
um anyway he did have a growing family
but in his head so he had to provide for
them but in his head he was devoted to
the bygone subsistence economy of the
past the the economy when you lived off
the land when you lived off the land and
you farmed your own goods but he tried
to plunge into capitalism and he had
neither the will nor the flexibility to
do so he was also the victim of
circumstance because the year that he
entered the capitalist arena 1837 was
the beginning of a five-year depression
the greatest depression before the Great
Depression and actually if he had held
on to some of the properties that he had
accumulated during that time he would
have been a very rich man later on
because he made very wise real estate
decisions but it was a terrible time and
that was part of the reason as it was he
did go bankrupt and he was sued by his
creditors and he spent a lot of time in
court although I should say that nobody
saw him is willfully corrupt as serve a
bad guy
and to the end of his life he tried to
kind of pay people back it was kind of
pathetic you know ten dollars here
twenty five dollars there these people
that he knew he owed money to and he
adopted anti-slavery violence in the
1850s because that take decades saw
slavery become embedded in America in a
way that seemed permanent slavery was
enforced by several governmental acts
defeated slave law the kansas-nebraska
Act and the Dred Scott decision in the
South slavery was increasingly seen as a
positive good and this is very different
from Jefferson's day even though
Jefferson had been a slave holder he had
said basically it's a bad thing it's
gonna it should go away by this time it
was seen as what Calhoun called a
positive good it was good it was good
for blacks it was good for whites it
wasn't a bad thing it was good it was a
noble institution that must be spread
and some southerners in
including Alexander Stephens the future
of vice president of the Confederacy
strongly recommended that we take over
Africa to enslave its millions and why
to expose them to Christian Western
culture so not just a good thing for
America but good for the world and in
the North there was a lot of
anti-slavery feeling but very little
anti-slavery action the leading
abolitionists like William Lloyd
Garrison and Wendell Phillips were
pacifists who thought there were dis
unionists they believed that the nation
should be divided between the north and
the south and the South should go its
own own way and then kind of like a
rotting rotting fruit fruit on the vine
eventually slavery would slowly
disappear Lincoln and the Republican
Party hated slavery just as much as John
Brown did but they loved the American
Union and therefore they recoiled from
the idea of war they didn't like John
Brown shortly before the war Lincoln
declared war is not the answer
and he he predicted slavery would slowly
disappear on its own though he thought
it might take a century he said about a
hundred years from now it'll it'll
eventually disappear John Brown thought
otherwise he was driven to a fury by
what he thought was the North's cowardly
response to pro-slavery violence he was
appalled that people were flocking into
Kansas Kansas was a territory that was
poised between between becoming
pro-slavery or an anti-slavery and he
was appalled that these Missourians were
flocking and taking over the polling
booths and electing fraudulent
governments in in Kansas not only that
but the gut these fraudulent governments
were being applauded and endorsed by the
national government by President
Franklin Pierce and James Buchanan
meanwhile pro-slavery newspapers
preached murderous violence against
abolitionists in the state and what the
newspapers preached the pro-slavery
settlers practiced John Brown's violence
in Kansas has never been fully put into
context yes he did supervised five
murders at Potawatomi Creek and in the
confusion of the Kansas legal system
used he was never brought to justice but
my research shows that
thirty-eight recorded political murders
committed in Kansas between 1855 and
1858 28 were committed by the
pro-slavery side and only eight by the
anti-slavery side John Brown was
responsible for five of those eight
murders Brown felt as Johnny violence
was justified no long not only by
pro-slavery action in Kansas but also by
centuries of cruelty to blacks for him
slavery itself was a state of war
against an entire race you have to
realize that of nearly 30 million people
there were formed nearly 4 million
enslaved blacks at that time he was also
giving the South some of its own
medicine he was getting back for decades
of unavenged violence committed by
southerners against whites against
slaves against free blacks against
visiting northerners who was suspected
of abolitionism recent studies have
shown that over 80% of the acts of
vigilante violence by southern whites
went unpunished the code of the
chivalric Southern gentleman at that
time was laced with machismo and
aggression the South then was a culture
of dueling bowie knives deadly feuds no
one thought the less of the southern
President Andrew Jackson because he had
killed a man in duel and had threatened
to kill a number of others
Mark Twain parodied southern culture in
his portrait of Huckleberry Finn in the
family feud between the Shepherdsons and
Grangerfords he may recall how Huck
learns about the feud buck Ranger
foretells Huck a feud is this way a man
has a quarrel with another man kills him
then that other man's brother kills him
then the other brothers on both sides
goes from one another then the cousins
chip in and by and by everybody's killed
off and there ain't no more feud now
obviously this was a slight exaggeration
but it represented kind of the culture
of southern violence that John Brown was
responding to and a contemporary
journalist wrote quote John Brown has
brought violence southern tactics to the
northern side it was kind of understood
at that time what he was doing and from
his perspective as violence paid off
because the south developed a panic
about John Brown that grew with his
later violent actions one in 1858 he
liberated those 11 slaves in Missouri
and took them on that 1200 mile trek
across the country to freedom the daring
escapade was performed in the full face
of the entire nation the Kansas governor
put $3,000 on his head
President James Buchanan added $250
prompting Browns joked that he'd gladly
pay two dollars and 50 cents for the
head of James Buchanan and the reason he
got away with it I mean he was kind of
pursued the whole way but Brown just
said it's perfectly well understood that
I'm not going to be taken and he didn't
even put out Scouts or anything he's
just kind of tramped across the entire
country now many have called John Brown
crazy for thinking that he could uproot
the slave system by attacking the south
with just 21 men recent events however
suggest that his plan was more feasible
than was long thought his plan was to
make a quick strike rally hundreds of
emancipated blacks to his side then flee
with them to the Appalachian Mountains
which ran deep into the south his aim
was to scatter small groups of black and
whites somewhat like today's terrorist
cells along the Appalachian chain using
the mountainous terrain as a defense
against pursuing forces it was a careful
student of guerilla warfare and he
thought he could evade vastly superior
forces by using caves there's also a
surveyor he had surveyed a lot of the
mountains by using caves and other
natural defenses in the mountains the
success of such a strategy by the Afghan
guerrillas against the immense Soviet
Army or more recently by Osama bin Laden
against the vastly superior US military
in the mountains suggests that this was
not necessarily a crack crack brain
scheme however Brown did miscalculate by
expecting an immediate massive response
on the part of the liberated blacks he
anticipated in his words that quote the
bees will hive he thought that there
will be the sudden uprising as soon as
he struck Harpers Ferry a little bit
like the nat turner situation where
there was this guy caught on like
wildfire but the slaves in the area were
unprepared they didn't respond the way
he'd expected yes some of them joined
them but many I mean many did just half
reluctantly
he and Brown was disappointed by the
lackluster response he said so after
after the raid even by the lackluster
response he stalled fatally and it was
because he stalled as I said he very
easily took over the town of it that was
no problem but he stalled and then after
a long battle he was taken by robert e
lee so this is the delay that doomed his
effort I don't think that we shouldn't
necessarily be surprised that the
enslaved blacks did act with a certain
amount of confusion it's a little bit
like if a Martian just walked in this
room I mean for to be oppressed and
degraded for so long and then suddenly a
white man comes at midnight and says
you're free and not only that but I give
you weapons to kill your master if if
your master does the wrong thing it it
would be a shocking thing I think for a
/ for anybody and it's kind of amazing
that actually some of them instantly did
join him and and kind of fight against
the opponents at any rate he did stall
he was captured and ironically the South
praised John Brown in the early going
much more strongly than the North did
why because he was a man of guts and
what what was the harm of praising him
obviously was completely nuts the South
hated him obviously but Alisa was one
northerner that that stood up had a
little little backbone to him and stood
up and showed a little fight and so by
far the strongest play praise were from
his captors governor wise of Virginia
and so forth and the North meanwhile
completely dammed him I've read all the
newspaper accounts and they completely
damned him until Henry David Thoreau
came out and in his very famous talk a
plea for Captain John Brown he said he
is pure he cannot be tried by his peers
because his peers do not exist and Henry
David Thoreau if you have ever here was
not someone to genuflect to anybody but
he genuflected to John Brown and people
said hmm that's kind of interesting and
then when Ralph Waldo Emerson millions
of Americans saw the American Revolution
through Emerson sighs because he's the
one who said the shot heard around the
world
and everyone even today how many people
have heard that that statement many
people even today that those concord
farmers heard the shot heard around
emerson and said that and he came out
and said John Brown will make the
gallows as glorious as the cross and
that was like a bullet itself that kind
of you know ricocheted throughout
American culture it totally outraged the
south and suddenly the South kind of
shut up about John Brown he wasn't this
great guy anymore
he was devil he was Satan and more than
that everybody in the north was Satan
and devil and there were a bunch of John
Brown's too suddenly there was a
flip-flop and slowly the North kind of
very slowly came around to the
Emersonian view of John Brown which is
this great hero and this great martyr I
don't think anybody ever went as far as
saying Jesus Christ the way you know
Emerson did but there were a lot of
people that that suddenly were kind of
magnetized by that statement and and it
kind of gathered so that by the time of
the Civil War the Union troops went to
battle singing John Brown's body lies a
moldering in the grave but his soul
keeps marching on and even to this day a
lot of people have heard that that song
still survives and it was the most
popular Union song northern a song in in
the northern army and not only that but
it fed into the Battle Hymn of the
Republic
because when Julia Ward Howe heard it
being sung in Washington by some troops
she went home at 4:00 in the morning she
woke up and he was kind of ringing in
her ears and she wrote to the same tune
the Battle Hymn of the Republic and then
at that point John Brown becomes his
spirit in a sense become fused with
almost the definition of America at that
point and ironically enough well at the
beginning of the war Abe Lincoln says I
don't want to attack the south why well
that would be nothing but a massive John
Brown raid on the south he said I don't
want war that that should just mean
nothing but a John Brown raid on the
south but reluctantly he had to call up
75,000 troops
and Fort Sumter was fired on and he was
kind of sucked into the war and pretty
soon he was engaged in what many
southerners called a massive John Brown
rate because by the end of the war it
was a war for liberation on the part of
the Norman northern army that attacked
the south trying to free the slaves and
shortly before the end of the war there
was one southerner who had been at the
hanging of John Brown John Wilkes Booth
who had been at the hanging he was a he
had left his job in Richmond he was an
actor he was like the Brad Pitt of his
day the pretty boy the ladies liked him
you know the the he was actually sort of
a hambone in two-bit actors father was a
pretty great actor his brother Edwin
Booth was a great actor he was sort of I
mean melodrama kind of kind of guy and
he saw things in black and white and he
saw John Brown hanging and again he
detested John Brown obviously detest him
but he said John Brown is the grandest
man of the century why he changed
history with a single stroke and this
guy booth had played a lot of these
villains Brutus and so there's a book
called American Brutus recently about
him you know who changed history with a
single stroke and he became so
disappointed by the direction history
was taking at the end of the Civil War
after writing this in his journal about
John Brown he decided to become John
Brown in Reverse and change history with
a single stroke of course by that time
that caused the cause of slavery was
gone with the wind and the last words
reported words of John of John Wilkes
Booth when he was captured in a barn
were useless useless and so in a sense
this is kind of John Brown Padre you
know an imitation of John Brown
puttering out and dying and with it the
southern cause then what happened is
that basically John Brown continued to
be a hero in the north and a demon in
the south right through reconstruction
as you all know reconstruction collapses
in 1876 and then there's this very long
period of Jim Crow and the Ku Klux Klan
and between 1876 and brown v board in
1954
and during that period John Brown is put
on this put basically in the loony bin
the loony bin of American history
murderer Horst the villain of the
deepest die and even historians kind of
catch catch this kind of envision of
John Brown and thence with simple rights
with with with the rise of civil rights
there's a little bit of a recuperation
but even to this very day for example
not too long ago when Trent Lott was
still the leader of the Senate a senator
from Kansas proposed a bill that would
have instituted some kind of national
recognition John Brown a John Brown day
or you know something and lot just said
he was from Mississippi and he's just
that over my dead body over my dead body
and you know you know there was just no
way and you know there are a lot of
people even to this day if I was on the
Diane Rehm show this morning and you
know there were a couple of callers who
were pretty pretty angry at me and there
might be people angry at me today but I
as a historian went back there kind of
thinking I guess the way everybody else
did this guy's sort of a loony bin type
now it was kind of you know shocked and
surprised that that I found so so much
evidence there of progressive thinking
and I found really very little
surprisingly little evidence of insanity
except I must say in 1842 when those
four kids died in a row there were a
couple people you read his letters then
and yeah I used to were depressed then
because even you used the word depressed
that was kind of the word that they use
back the MIDI he actually used the word
depressed and suicidal I thought that
was in 1842 long before I was very on
the other hand I wonder how many people
in this audience or in America wouldn't
feel a little bit suicidal if they lost
four kids and these were beloved
children who died very quickly in a row
so in a sense I give them a little
leeway there but you know other than
that in terms of things like mood swings
you know violent emotion and all that
stuff i I really don't don't don't see
it in him in any kind of you know
consistent way
and unlike many people I just I just
don't buy the idea of the insanity in
fact when the insanity defense came up
by his own lawyer during the trial his
lawyer said why don't we go with the
insanity thing you can go off off of
this thing with insanity
he said that's fine but I just don't
feel that way I don't feel insane I'm
not insane and when you read his letters
in prison Henry David Thoreau's said
John Brown didn't change anything
through his rifles his rifles were
complete failures it was his words his
words of course he could what happens
that unlike Sodom was sane we don't know
what Sodom was saying is thinking
day-to-day unlike that the prisons then
were porous newspaper reporters went in
and out and Muslim were pro-slavery so
they hated John Brown's but they planted
his words his crazy words in all the
newspapers
that went throughout the world and these
crazy words are ultimately what inspired
the north and when Emerson compared him
to Jesus Christ he was thinking
specifically about the day when John
Brown was told he was going to hang the
judge said you're gonna hang by the neck
and he's and John Brown uttered his
speech and said he uttered he very
straightforwardly gave his anti-slavery
views in about 250 words and Emerson
said there are two great American
speeches the Gettysburg Address and John
Brown's speech to the to the Virginia
Court they're two to two very good you
know speeches by Americans and if you
read that even to this day and even
though John Brown wouldn't passing was
101 I mean he was teacher I probably
flunk no I opened flunk John Bradley you
know what I mean I mean every sentence
had a semicolon in the wrong place and a
comma here and you know so forth and he
said I know about as much grammars one
of your calves in spite of that Thoreau
said John Brown defines standard English
because of the muscle of what what what
he was talking about his vision his
vision came through his words and that's
what what counted it's what he was
saying and so in a sense it's his words
that really won the day
and this is what for me differentiates
him from a lot of modern terrorists who
have acted in his name he was the hero
of Timothy McVeigh he was the hero of
Paul Hill who killed the abortion doctor
and was executed he's been the hero of a
lot of modern terrorists deterrence is
let's look at McVeigh what were his last
words he wrote down a poem called
Invictus it's me against the world
me me me it's what were John Brown's
last words all his letters toward the
end were about the suffering of black
children under slavery the families that
were ripped apart because of slavery the
people that were being murdered and
tortured because of slavery that's what
his last letters were about and he when
he was asked do you want to minister to
give you your last rites
he said no get me the most wretched
ragged enslaved black children that you
can find and let them accompany me to
the gallows
let them be my ministers and so you know
that that's a lot different than saying
Invictus me me look at me against the
government that kind of thing and it's a
lot different than the kind of
meandering kind of garbled Unabomber
the Kaczynski manifesto that he
attempted to sway people with but it was
completely rhetorically very very weak
and repetitive and so forth and Paul
Hill didn't articulate his views so
whatsoever so you know it's a little
wrong just to say John Brown and
terrorists and so forth have to be a
little bit careful with that kind of
equation anyway it's open for questions
you know thanks a lot for coming out do
we have any questions you know from the
audience yeah
the question I'm curious about the
historiography of Brown in the
post-world War two period seems like it
was very very negative and I wonder if
that's somehow a reflection of kind of
how the establishment saw race relations
here in the United States at the time I
don't know I was just wondering if if
you would address that issue in the
post-world War two area yeah
well I mean in the entire really the
entire 20th century until about the
sixties the only people that were
consistently praising Brown were African
Americans w ee b Dubois who founded the
Niagara movement was which a lot of
people see as the beginning of the civil
rights movement wrote a biography of
John Brown and the first meeting of the
night Niagara movement was at Harpers
Ferry and they made a long trek down to
Harpers Ferry specifically to be where
John Brown had died for blacks so and
then Dubois Langston Hughes and later a
lot of the civil rights activists of the
50s and 60s kept his memory alive but
you knew it was it was basically because
of the racial situation that had still
persisted at that time that there was
still a lot of extreme animosity against
John Brown without seeing the other side
yeah yeah
what you mentioned that he miscalculated
badly in terms of at Harpers Ferry
whether that the local black population
would rise up and follow him what upon
what grounds did he assume that that
would happen I mean he had a very
idealistic he was envisaging this whole
strength through the lens and probably
distorted lens of slave revolts there
have been 250 slave revolts roughly you
know before the Civil War and but to see
the big thing about them was that they
emerged from within the enslaved blacks
themselves they they they they took fire
and they slowly they smolder and then
they exploded but he had this idea that
somehow he could trigger this from
without he had a little bit had to be
very careful about telling too many of
the slaves beforehand and preparing them
too much beforehand because easily the
word could have could have gotten out
and he was camped actually near Harpers
Ferry for a couple of months trying to
get recruits and so he had to be a
little bit careful about the broad
spreading the word too much so they were
unprepared and he had this I see there's
been over idealistic vision from his
perspective of the kind of excitement
that would be generated but that really
the history of slave revolts show that
that it had to kind of come like a fire
from within and then a kind of
organization could could you know it
could flash out and explode but there
was very very little to recommend his
vision ultimately that from without
somehow you get automatically you know
he almost thought was like gasoline you
just throw the the spark on there and
and would explode question and my
understanding is is that Western
Virginia was not the most heavily
populated part of the state in terms of
slaves so it seems like he wasn't quite
encumbered by the thought process with
yeah
western virginia was not heavily popular
with slaves and some people say well why
did he attack that area on the other
hand almost all of the slaves that came
up on the Underground Railroad came from
the extreme northern part of the south I
mean that was and below that it was
pretty locked up I mean it was very hard
to kind of penetrate particularly in
camp out and try to recruit Pete he had
people straggling in and so forth and
and this was relatively near the border
with the north and he could kind of was
trying to get as many he only got 21
people as it was he wanted many more
people to come down and he expected more
people Harriet Tubman supposedly was
supposed to be there and you know many
other people but that they just didn't
make it kept him waiting and waiting and
finally said let's go ahead with us so
part of it was logistics yeah yeah yeah
yeah exactly did you have a question to
what kind of a family man was he he
seems to have am pretty difficult with
his sons and of course so many of his
sons were killed in the course of this
early on he was like a typical Stern
father of the time a kind of patriarch
who beat his sons on the other hand
spare the rod and spoil the child was
kind of a common ethic of that of that
day particularly earlier in the century
later on he became a very tender father
and and would hold his kids on his laps
and his lap and so forth but he also had
this kind of I don't know if we want to
call it macho or whatever or just
courageous thing and and when his son
was dying by his side his son died it
was shot in the balls and it took him
about 16 hours to die it was slowly
bleeding to death and his son was lying
there in in complete agony and like any
of us would do was crying out in pain
and and finally his son said you know
dad put me out of my misery just just
shoot me through the head and John Brown
said hush up and die like him if you'd
uh if die you must die like a man and
you know it's it I mean that in what
when he when he's that quote courageous
or whatever you want to call it almost
verges on on a kind of cruelty I
we'll say however on the way to the
gallows he was he was calmer than than
anyone everybody else was kind of
nervous and he was just looking he said
the countryside around here this part of
Virginia is very pretty you know I I
haven't seen this this is very pretty
and the only thing that bothered him was
that he had to wait in the gallows he
was up there for a good number of
minutes and he was positioned over the
trap and everything to put the thing in
his head he said okay fine but don't
keep me waiting too long but the troops
there were over a thousand troops they
had to position they took about 10 or 15
minutes to jockey into position it was
kind of standing there just just kind of
waiting for it but I mean he did have a
certain backbone which which sometimes I
don't know too many people who have you
know quite you know quite as much Moxie
or whatever you want to call it as as he
but to justify I mean these are innocent
sellers I mean they were on the other
side and that thing was happening of
course they're literally of doing that
kind of thing after liberating the those
those 11 slaves or you mean or you mean
by killing by slaughtering these white
settlers right yeah yeah well he you
know that was partly a direct response
to the destruction of Lawrence the Free
State Capitol by the border the mers of
Missouri border ruffians and also some
of the people he killed had directly
threatened the whole Brown family they
said we're gonna wipe out the
abolitionists and particularly the
Browns and one of them had threatened he
killed his son his son and also he
learned about the beating of Charles
Sumner by Preston Brooks on the floor of
the Senate Senate in which as you know
Preston Brooks a relative of his was
insulted by the anti-slavery orator
Charles Sumner and he came to the US
Senate with a cane with a Medal of head
and beat you know Sumner to a pulp he
thought he killed him and there was a
bloody mess on the floor and everything
so so and when John Brown heard about
this he was just totally enrage
- so you know they were very very kind
of explosive situation but I mean in my
book I do I just say it is a crime you
know I mean it was a crime that that he
committed no matter what but I do try to
put it in the context of other crimes
that that were happening yeah yeah yeah
Brown said I guess on the way to his
execution he was now firmly convinced
that this issue of slavery would end in
bloodshed is there anything else he said
I wrote in his last days to indicate he
predicted something of the magnitude of
civil war or that he ultimately would
succeed and as you put a killing slavery
yeah well he did say that on the way to
the gallows once again it wasn't quite
like like McVeigh or something myself he
said I I hate to say it I'm just
paraphrasing him but the crimes of this
guilty nation are going to be washed
away only in blood and I'm very sorry
but I think that very much bloodshed
he's going to going to occur here and as
all of us know six hundred and twenty
thousand Americans died more Americans
than all Americans that were killed in
all other wars combined combined if you
combine all other wars more Americans
died so it did take a lot of bloodshed
to get rid of slavery
and yeah about a year before that he had
had a conversation in Kansas with
someone in a hotel and the guy thought
he was crazy
he said I believe this thing is going to
result in a massive and very very bloody
war he says I I don't want it to happen
but I think it's gonna happen and I hate
to say it and the guy thought is totally
loony you know but he said you know
maybe it won't happen but I think it's
going to so yeah he made that prediction
but yeah do in writing the book about
John Brown if you thought that perhaps
actually okay what what what was that
why did you choose to write a book about
John Brown well um I happen to be a
professor of English and American
Studies I've taught English for many
many I was gonna say decades it seems
like decades any several decades and I
noticed all these people writing about
him Emerson Thoreau Victor Hugo in late
miserab said he's greater than George
Washington John Brown is greater than
George Washington and more important and
Whittier Longfellow and on and on all
these writers and you know I was kind of
coming here from that angle and and yet
on the other hand any time I mentioned
John Brown to any of my colleagues he
said they'd said you know obviously it
was just a nut he was crazy and somehow
the two images didn't didn't come
together in my mind I was just very very
curious about this disparity and I tried
to read him about him in the mainstream
history books and they kind of shoved
him off to the side there's a book
published in 1998 and it's a very good
book but it's called why the war came
why the Civil War came doesn't even
mention John Brown not even a one man
you mentioned Lincoln the Republican
Party and everything and even Ken Burns
a civil war kind of mentions him in
passing it's kind of but anyway servo
firebrand and self-worth but shuts him
off the side so I was kind of a little
curious about it and then of course 9/11
happened and he'd be seemed all the more
relevant and then a novel like Gilead
Gilead featured John Brown and then
there was a novel called cloud splitter
by Russell banks and suddenly he came
into consciousness at the same time that
I was thinking about him and I just got
more and more involved with him so and
it was a very interesting project you
know I just
anytime I write a book I try to revisit
the culture in which a certain person
lived I try to I believe I write what I
call cultural biography which means
every one of us is in a particular place
in time and even unconsciously were
defined by so many things around us that
we're not even aware of the images
though that we see and the things that
we hear they're kind of seep into our
consciousness and in my book what I try
to do is bring back his world and his
perspective just as I did in Walt
Whitman's America and I tried to do the
same thing for Walt Whitman that I did
for John Brown yeah what happened to his
immediate family after his death was
suspended yeah they were in very very
poor very poverty-stricken pardon me
well you know the the people that came
the most to their aid were of all people
the people that could least afford it a
group of black women gathered together
and I mean there were no there was no
group in America except for maybe Native
American women who could Lila less
afford it but they kind of did what they
could they they gathered Dimes and
everything and they they tried to gather
money for Mary Brown and and her family
and so forth and then some of the sons
did become far Muslim became farmers one
of them went to California some of them
became involved in the civil war and
anti-slavery activity and so forth but
you know it was it was kind of a sad
poverty-stricken and also he was like
the dynamic core of their family and
such a polarizing figure that as
important as he was he was also in some
ways difficult to live with because he
became a larger-than-life figure and
it's almost like someone becoming a
celebrity in your family and you know
how do you relate to this person and
you're just this kind of you know this
this humble family down here and you
know there were some difficulties so
yeah there was a cabal who were
supporting him and financing his
activities see there's something called
a secret six that were supporting him
and financing him and most of them
cowered with fear
after Harpers Ferry because they were
scared they were gonna get caught what
they did is most of them destroyed the
letters one of them McGarrett Smith who
knew more about Harpers Ferry than
anybody
it was a very rich man and very
well-intentioned and he supported
Harpers Ferry the whole thing but he had
to be committed to the Utica lunatic
asylum because he was overcome with with
visions of guilt and everything and he
thought he was going to die and all this
so he actually went into an insane
asylum when he came out of it people
tried to blame him with they even
suggested you had knowledge of Harpers
Ferry said I did not and he actually
sued people for hundreds of thousands of
dollars for even implying and he knew
more about Harpers Ferry than almost
anybody except John Brown so and to the
end of his life he completely withdrew
himself from John Brown Frederick
Douglass a guy that I admired a lot
nevertheless took the step of leaving
the country immediately after Harpers
Ferry and he fled to Canada and then
England and then came back later when it
had blown over another supporter named
how almost went nuts he felt he was
going crazy and he left for a while and
he burned all his letters so most of his
supporters only one of them Thomas
Wentworth Higginson actually stood by
John Brown and came out and said he I
supported John Brown but ironically they
had a big Senate investigation of the
genre they didn't call Higginson why
they are actually it was a tinderbox
they didn't want this thing to explode
into a civil war right then because it
was a time when virtually everyone in
the Senate and the House of
Representatives and anyone who didn't
have one gun was carrying two guns and a
number of people bought brought shotguns
you know in so is a very very explosive
situation so this so-called
investigation was actually pussyfoot
cover-up kind of thing well let's let's
shove this thing aside and not really
investigate it they didn't call
Higginson and they swallowed all the
lies of the secret six and all that
stuff's who were covering up so book all
the secret six I forgot the name of the
author which is a pretty good book but
I'm really the only one who kind of
follows up the aftermath of the Harpers
Ferry thing and what they all did after
it because like a lot of my book is are
tracing the impact of John Brown his
implications not only for the Civil War
for but for modern America as well so my
last chapter is really about how the
meaning of John Brown fans out and
ironically the John Brown song John
Brown's body lies moldering in the grave
was not about John Brown whatsoever
initially at first it was a southern
song it was a joke
say Hummers will you meet meet us it was
a campfire song then it became a
Southern Methodist hymn say brothers say
and then people started humming it up in
the twelfth Massachusetts regiment
outside of Boston early in the Civil War
and there was a guy named John Brown
they're a little private soldier who
happened to be late quite often for the
drills so they said Oh John Brown's lazy
he's dead and they said John Brown
Brown's body lies smoldering in the
grave haha isn't that funny
and suddenly they started seeing that
old Methodist hymn and said hmm this
could be about John Brown the real John
Brown and then pretty soon the only
regiment that didn't sing that song was
the twelfth Massachusetts because
they're John Brown that little private
died by falling off a pontoon early in
the Civil War so there was a one
regiment that refused to sing that song
it was too painful for them after that
yeah you may have answered the question
but when did this idea of John Brown
deluna
begin when you know wouldn't it people
start receiving him well if just after
Harpers Ferry a lot of the Southerners
well initially they praise him but the
but then they called him crazy but the
lunatic thing really kicked in in the
1880s just after reconstruction
collapsed and I won't get the histories
in my book but basically yeah a series
of people came out and said he was crazy
and then a number of historians
including the famous Allan Nevins Allan
Nevins who was a very very famous Civil
War historian said he should have been
in a hospital for the criminally insane
that that's what he should have been and
why did that arise because during that
whole period I mentioned of segregation
and Jim Crow even historians to some
degree reflected the temper of that era
and so they demonized John Brown and
else in other extreme abolitionists and
and they called him crazy yes yeah I
mean the when John Brown came to Concord
shortly after the Pottawatomie massacre
and he described his violent methods he
didn't admit to Potawatomi to them
explicitly but the roast said that a guy
like John Brown should be made a hero of
even if he were the most vile murderer
that's what Thoreau said it was kind of
shocking to say that that's into roast
speech about John Brown and Potawatomi
was uttered was described on the floor
of the United States Senate in 1856 it
was known publicly and a lot of my
research shows that it became public
knowledge much more so than previous
biographers have realized I go back to
the newspapers of the day and I show and
the Senate reports and it was there and
even after everybody in the world knew
it because the New York Herald
shortly after Harpers Ferry said John
Brown pulled these five people out and
slaughter them at Potawatomi even after
that
actually Emerson kept referring to him
to Jesus Christ and so forth even even
in full knowledge of all of that so yeah
pert pretty amazing this was kind of
Jesus Christ with a sword or something
you know this was you know I kind of
oxymoron really I mean you know using
the sword in in the name of justice but
are there any more comments or you
mention that Brown had written numerous
letters did he have any other writings
that were primary sources that were
available to you or did they sort of get
filtered through the press yeah I wrote
an autobiography
yeah and because the little boy said
will you tell me your background and he
said yeah he wrote it down and sent it
to the little boy and so that's
available and then a lot of letters and
his some of his speeches are still
around and they're collected in a recent
anthology and so forth but anyway thank
you very much for coming
and David Reynolds was awarded the 1996
Bancroft prize for Walt Whitman's
America
his latest John Brown abolitionist is
published by Knopf visit a a Knopf
dot-com